welcome back to grammar and filtered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the queen of pop yes honey's
and Larry how are you babe I'm good oh
yeah yeah you getting a workout with the
nails in babes getting these fingers
limbered our birth date is out right now
listen to it get on it ASAP new albums
on the way what does the new music say
about you as a person sitting here today
do you think if you listen to all my
music you will be able to tell how I
felt at that time it wasn't as if I like
when in a shoe Joanne was like laughter
like crap but that's right
flowers I actually wrote about that
moment in time so I think with this
album you can tell where I am at in my
brain you were always very
autobiographical when you write what do
you think's been the hardest thing for
you to be honest about with yourself
when it comes to writing and being this
you do the best songs are when you just
tell everything for me so yeah they're
almost the easiest ones to write the
hardest wants me when I have to make
something up that I haven't felt yeah so
much yeah drink five tequila's in a row
never done it before so how do I write
about it so weirdly the most vulnerable
and real songs are like what come out
the easiest for me which is great
because this kind of therapy session as
well like we were saying you have been
so honest about different things you've
been free like for instance anxiety
before what is your relationship with
your own south like now would you say in
comparison to how it was it probably its
toughest time I wouldn't say now like
I'm totally fine and out of it I would
say that there was there was days where
it's like terrible but then two days
later I'm way better than what I was
before so I I just feel like I've
improved with that whole situation there
it's gonna be a constant battle I think
but to know that all that it will be
okay is the best feeling to to feel you
know how did you get yourself out of
there a lot of different things
I tried therapy hypnotherapy googling
helped a lot listening to other people's
stories writing it down repeats I've
literally done everything you can do
I think hypnotherapy was that really a
big part of it and I guess talking and
listening to other people helped that's
why I think it's so important for people
to talk about what they go for is
because you almost feel like you're okay
when you hear someone else saying it so
yeah I've pretty much done everything
you can to help me do you think
anxieties taught you a lot about your
power as a person I honestly feel like I
am i I've got myself out of it from
other people though so it's almost like
I'm not sure if it was me yeah I think
maybe later on down the line I'll be
like no that differently yeah was myself
getting myself out of it that's why I
speak by so much because hopefully I
will be that person to what someone else
was to me you know it's hard boy when it
was it's hard s what was it like for you
thoughts of the dire thought my family
were gonna die it was honestly it was a
mixture of a lot of things though like
OCD a lot of different parts added to
the anxiety as well so and that's
annoying for me because I was so
adventurous when I was younger and I was
I did everything and I didn't care about
hurting my leg or you know anything like
that so when I went through this I was
like wow I'm literally I'm a different
person now and I don't like it at the
worst time I think I was just like wow
how am I even gonna go on stage how am I
gonna do what I do when I've worked so
hard and so long to get to this point
and now I'm like I don't even want to do
it now I can walk into rooms first which
is great and I can answer the phone
which I what never used to be able to do
it's it was intense
I guess because you know you can get
through it you can tell yourself that
that's so powerful that's why I say all
the time like however bad you're feeling
right now it can't get worse
from that moment so that's that's why I
kept on having to tell myself if you
could sit the youth down he was going
for it right now what would you want to
say to her try and help yourself as soon
as possible
don't let get to a really bad place and
I think people only start to deal with
their problems when it gets to a certain
badness you know that's when it gets
even worse and then you're just like
what am I going to do so I think I would
have liked to have said to myself even
sooner start searching about it start
looking at how you feel come to some
realizations talk to your friends go to
therapy like all that stuff I just think
I would have said do it sooner rather
than let get to a really extreme place
to do something about it
what do you mean therapy and talking
about is taught you when I think of
sinking my head it's so bad and as soon
as I say out of my mouth it's like 25
percent of how I thought it was gonna be
I am so lucky that I'm able to write it
in songs yeah I think without that I
would have been a recluse I would have
just been in I wonder sign I don't know
what I would have done with my life to
be honest if you're too scared to like
go to someone or worried about what
people gonna think about you want people
judging you just write a tweet or write
on a piece of paper next to your bed or
just write it so it's in existence there
in front of you rather than just in your
brain because that just goes like that
you know because one of the amazing
things about you as a fangirl my South
babes yes I have is that you are so
great in encouraging girls and guys
anywhere no matter what your age is to
love themselves and embrace
imperfections and all those amazing
things you've done especially in your
songwriting what's that what's your
journey been like that for you in the
terms of self-acceptance how do you
learn to accept yourself when I became
conscious of how I looked because of
stuff like magazines and pictures online
and of other people that you see and you
then set yourself against that person I
think that happened when I was like 13
14 and then that was it really that was
like I'm with
myself anymore cuz I wish I had that and
I wish I had that I remember when I was
in school and I had like hips
I'd actually formed hips when I was a
teenager and I used to get picked on for
having hips so in the whole of my
teenage years I was like I'm not gonna
eat food because I don't want to have
big hips and then when I got older I was
like actually I do want hips because
they're sick so then I started munching
loads of food so I think what happened
with me is that I always went through
something and then ended up wanting to
be the opposite and then the opposite of
that and the opposite of that and I
think what I had to learn is that you
can change the outside layer but like my
bones are the size that my bones are and
my body is only gonna go around my bones
to a certain degree you know for me it
was always a case of like oh I want to
be thin I want to be slim I want to be
thick I want a big bomb I want like all
this stuff and then I just got to a
point where I was like when I'm skinny
I'm not healthy like what - skinny I'm
not healthy and when I'm when I've got
weight on my body like too much weight
my have no energy so I got to the point
- like I just need my boy needs to be
where it's supposed to be it's it's easy
to speak to girls for me because I'm a
girl and it's I've been through it so I
think when I was growing up and then I
wanted to make music I was like how do I
reach boys because I didn't grow up as a
boy so I how do I help them and I think
it's been quite crazy for me knowing how
hard boys have it and it's it's an
eye-opener because you think I was quite
bad which we do like obviously but it's
equal for everyone like we've got we've
all got things going on and I'm now
trying them really hard to get my head
around how boys feel yeah you know
because also the thing is is that body
image issues are genderless like I had
them so badly when I was growing up and
in fact my early 20s it's only recently
that I've been able to like get over it
well not get overexcited as there isn't
you never a finished product you're
never gonna sit here and be like I'm so
great right now love every single part
of me but you have to get to that place
where you do accept yourself more
because do you feel more comfortable you
your own skin than ever before would you
say now yeah definitely but it's taken
too long I think that's what my issue is
like if I just started this self-love
journey a little bit sooner I would have
had all my twenties to have fun I feel
like I feel like my twenties were a lot
of learning and her and dealing with
stuff that I shouldn't have had to do
that's why I like to talk to younger
people because I'm like if you have
problems deal with them now so in your
20s you can have like good laugh you
know five tequila's like you're saying
earlier behaves embrace that was there a
turning point a Pacific turning point
you can remember in when you remember
thinking oh sure do you quite love
myself now it was probably at the start
of 2019 it's very very recent I think I
almost feel like because I had anxiety
really bad that I was I can't remember
that part of my life because it's just
gone and I can't if I look back the last
maybe seven to ten years of my life I
can't remember it because I was I had
anxiety and it almost blocked me from
thinking normally and remembering things
because I was so anxious about
everything and it was it wasn't until
2019 in January it was just random I
think I didn't do something and it
helped I think it was just one day I
woke up and I just felt like I was
actually like here and actually
experiencing my experiences rather than
just my brain being like this on
everything else now I feel like it's
here that's why it's there's no once to
say how did you get over it because it's
like I don't know don't know I didn't go
to therapy and then I was okay the next
day it was a build up of everything and
then one day it just kind of something
happened to my brain and I can't really
describe it or explain it do you think
the musical success is half of that as
well because you've had so much success
like you've done so well you've achieved
so much stuff already and you're only
gonna go on and achieve even more
is that helped with your self-esteem
this idea of success I think it's done
like both things because when I was
first making music I and throughout my
teenage years my urge and want to be
liked by everyone was so overpowering
that I was that was like a big part of
the anxiety is that when I was doing
music cuz I all I really want us to be
likes and if someone don't like me then
I failed to realize like not everyone's
gonna like here it's life yeah exactly
yeah but I think yeah the more the songs
did well and and the more you see them
in the charts and and you can go to
different countries and and perform
shows I think that was more of a just
like acceptance for me into a world yeah
I think that really did help actually
yeah now that it's just a realization
now because you said it but I never I
never thought that before we should give
you some up at the bat babes yeah give
that little part of the bat right here
and like I was saying I know you should
be so proud of yourself because I think
you're great
love you babes
[Music]